[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another episode
of Harry Potter theory as we all know
the books in the films have never
entirely matched up given that we all
read the books before the film's came
out there was a certain expectation from
the films and that was that they would
match the descriptions in the books from
scenes that are different altogether to
content that was removed to the physical
characteristics of some of the main
characters they've never quite been
consistent with one another one of the
main things that I noticed when I first
started watching the films was that the
characters didn't quite look the way
that they were described in the books
over the course of several videos I'm
going to be photoshopping images of
characters from the films so their
physical appearance matches the
descriptions in the novel for this first
video I'm going to be photoshopping Lord
Voldemort so sit back relax and enjoy
now I'd say the film's did a pretty good
job of portraying Tom Riddle before his
physical transformation into Lord
Voldemort they described him as handsome
tall thin pale and with jet-black hair
and dark eyes as we can see here Tom
Riddle in the film matches this
description quite well however after his
transformation into Voldemort things
starts to get a bit hazy here's a photo
of Voldemort handsome isn't he
take in as much as you can now in the
book he was described as being tall and
skeletally thin let's capitalize on his
first point make vol D a little bit
thinner
[Music]
there that looks good to me in addition
to being skeletally thin he was
described as having a choc white face
that resembled a skull the films were
almost accurate on the chalk white face
front but I think we can make it a
little bit whiter there we go I think
that'll do on the skull front I really
don't think that he resembles a skull
let's see what we can do to make this
handsome devil match the book all right
I think this is good enough for now I
don't want him to look like a total
skeleton but I thought I'd had a
skeletal type of effect to his existing
appearance now that he's almost reached
peak physical attractiveness let's move
on to the eyes Voldemort was described
as having vivid red eyes with vertical
cat-like pupils let's see what we can do
here and here we are beautiful
Voldemort's next descriptors were that
he had no hair so there's not much to do
there and that he had no discernible
lips let's work on that one and here we
go there's definitely still a little bit
of lip happening but they certainly
aren't voluptuous for the last and final
descriptor of our handsome friend it is
said that he had especially long and
thin hands I don't have much hand to
work with here and I'm almost certain
that I'm going to butcher this part but
let's see what I can do
whoa that's pretty awful and I'm really
not even sure how he's holding onto the
wand at this point but there you go and
with that last descriptor that pretty
much concludes the video here's a quick
before and after sample for you guys so
that you can appreciate my fine artistry
and with that being said comment down
below if you'd like me to do this for
next and remember help will always be
given at Hogwarts to those who deserve
it
[Music]